ного марокканська танку в obrigado
прибуде в Європи менше через рік вагою
та розмістити техніку то вікових web and
агоній покарають задум експертів весь до
розгорнути на територіях загрозу кілька
краю нічого не в тому закривав сусідніх
з українською болгарією та румунією поштою а
також українок балтії за галон США
збираються прокинутий і 4200 вельського
службу в 250 танків до 1711 транспорту
плани пентагону дзеркально рак тіан ідеї
Москви якоб порушу і міжнародні будинків
лінощі поважаючи весь кого експерт
Олександр Гольц
перевірку в Україні росія справа
таким чином
vita видно і віденського документа випад
куя що ви тут немає маневр і aquel
кисть скронь їх звички 8000 необхідно
золотить та міжнародних врятував 3 гачів
руси [ __ ] про раз з'явилася він не проводить
маневре столітті brute доля фанати 8000
ризикових виправдати кілька про креми
маневрі 1 година на одночасно пентагону
битися і рахунок танкова бригада не буде
знаходите себе в Європі на нехай і не
основі
особливого і склади мене в цьому і те коріння
9 місяців кремль uuid по адже коли
ще вашингтон лукавити і безперервно
рута тема лови дражнячи та civic пусти але та
військові злочинності теж росія
побачити на діяна то згоряєте
розмістить і засвої йому за хітом біля скроні
вам про вантаж дудакова дві дивізії топа на
тисячу цієї квіткові техніки